notre second débat dans ce sens public
quand la chine s'isole frappé par le
pire regain de l'épidémie qu'ovide
depuis deux ans la stratégie de pékin
est un échec ceux qui en subissent les
conséquences ce sont les habitants
durement confiné hublot lemonnier
pékin et ses 21 millions d'habitants de
nouveau soumise aux restrictions
seulement quelques centaines de cas
recensés dans la capitale et déjà les
files s'allongent devant les centres de
dépistage des campagnes de tests massive
premier volet de la stratégie zéro co
vie du parti communiste mais face à
cette vague au micron la situation
pourrait empirer et aboutira
déconfinement localisés comme un
shanghai devant les journalistes la
population réaffirme sa confiance dans
la politique du régime j'ai un ami à
shanghai qui est confiné travail à la
maison mais à pékin je ne pense pas que
ça va se produire c'est la capitale donc
la situation épidémique ne sera pas
aussi grave qu à shanghai shanghai ville
monde de 26 millions d'habitants devenue
le symbole de la répression chinoise
depuis le début du confinement de la
ville il ya un mois ces images font le
tour du globe
cette femme refuse d'ouvrir aux hommes
en blanc du gouvernement ils défoncent
la porte
et pour les personnes positives
direction les centre de quarantaine où
certains finissent par craquer
la nuit tombée concert de casseroles
pour les shanghaïens de ce quartier qui
crient famine faute d'approvisionnement
après cet échec de la stratégie zéro co
vide à shanghai le régime peut-il se
permettre un confinement aussi strictes
à pékin à ce stade les autorités se
veulent rassurantes
à l'heure actuelle il existe encore des
sources et par ses cachets d'infection
qu'ovide au niveau communautaire dans
tout pékin il est nécessaire d'accélérer
le dépistage dans les districts de
renforcer le contrôle en temps réel
d'empêcher la propagation du virus entre
les districts ya et d'endiguer
résolument la propagation d'épidémies
mais la vague ou micron gagne peu à peu
le poumon économique de la chine
des villes comme tianjin 8e port mondial
ou shenzhen capitale de la tec sont à
leur tour soumise à des restrictions au
point de menacer la croissance chinoise
et notre débat quand la chine s'isole je
vous présente mes invités sylvie bermann
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes ancienne
ambassadrice de france à pékin et à
moscou notamment marie holzman bonsoir
sinologue présidente de l'association
solidarité chine j'accueille elle ment
fille pas guinée bonsoir chercheur
associé au programme asie de l'institut
montaigne professeur d'économie chinoise
à l'institut national des langues et les
cultures orientales et à sciences po et
matthieu croissandeau est resté à mes
côtés ce il ya beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder qui sont qui sont passionnants
commence évidemment avec ce ce
confinement pire flambée de covin depuis
deux ans sylvie berman
le gouvernement at il fait des erreurs
est ce qu'on peut dire autre chose que
oui et je crois que oui c'est à dire que
finalement au début quand locaux vides a
éclaté c'était sans doute la bonne
politique puisqu'ils ont eu très peu de
morts si on compare aux millions de
morts américains quand même près et puis
à quelques centaines de milliers de
morts dans d'autres pays mais sauf
qu'aujourd'hui ça ne tient plus parce
que ça veut dire que c'est un pays qui
est totalement en fermer d'autres pays
d'asie avaient suivi la même politique
comme l'australie la nouvelle zélande y
ont renoncé et là c'est une politique
qui est très strict pour un
pour un virus qui est très différent du
premier ils n'ont pas accepter
d'importer ou du d'acheter la licence de
des
messages et est donc maintenant il est
piégé par cela et on comprend que la
population soit très mécontentes
d'autant plus que si vous confiné une
ville comme shanghai c'est très très
difficile d'organiser la logistique
l'approvisionnement certains se
plaignent d'avoir feint de ne pas être
livrés et donc aujourd'hui c'est une
politique qui ne tient plus marie
holzman c'est la police qui est à la
manoeuvre à shanghai pour faire
respecter ce second film en
chine maintenant 10 et les hommes en
blanc c'est à dire que ce sont des gens
qui soutiennent des détenus protectrice
comme ça donc on sait pas qui c'est
quelquefois c'est marqué police mais
quelques fois et rien de marquer et donc
il ya ceux qui ont un petit badge et
puis les autres ont un brassard autour
du bras et donc tout le monde dit on est
en train de retourner à la révolution
culturelle c'est à dire que ceux qui
sont dans ces tenues et qui ont un
brassard ils ont le pouvoir et c'est pas
nécessairement des policiers mais bon
peu importe que ce soit ou non ça peut
aussi dément être des membres des
comités de quartier mais ce que disent
les chinois c'est que à partir du moment
où ils sont masqués on les reconnaît pas
eh bien on vient de voir une scène de
violence quand même assez choquant de
quelqu'un qui se fait taper sur la tête
il crie
c'est ces gens là sont masquées donc ils
sont impunis même même s'ils font des
bêtises même si tu quelqu'un on sait pas
qui l'a fait donc c'est très angoissant
pour la population d'avoir ces espèces
de zombies qui se promène partout et
contre lesquels on peut pas résister
c'est impossible de pékin on a évoqué
finit pas guinée la situation à pékin
est ce que pékin va être en partie
confiné ou pas quand on parle de poids
économique des villes et des et des
grandes métropoles chinoises qui sont
gigantesques entre shanghai et pékin et
ça ça change quoi si pékin était aussi
confiné par ça change quand même pas mal
de choses dont shanghai c'est quand même
le principal poumon économique de la
chine enfin on peut dire shanghai et
shenzhen et le sud pékin s'est beaucoup
plus c'est la capitale administrative
politique et ça c'est très important
mais le poids économique est peut-être
un tout petit peu moindre alors on peut
aussi supposer que les autorités vont
essayer d'apprendre de pas je sais pas
comment l'appeler la débâcle de shanghai
c est
peut-être faire preuve de flexibilité
dans leur manière d'être inflexible si
je puis si je fus m'exprimer ainsi
en tout cas on voit bien que il essaye
de faire en sorte que deux
le confinement soit moins stricte avec
1,4 shanghai mais bon voilà vont-ils y
arriver on ne sait pas et les dernières
nouvelles il ya d'autres villes la
dernière c'est john john capitale du run
and quand même une ville de 100 mille
lieues de 10 millions par an aux
débutants qui assure de production très
important pour une société qui s'appelle
call comme dont thomas sans doute dont
on n'avait pas entendu parler mais qui
fabrique
la plus grande partie des instruments
comme
les tablettes d'ordinateurs et d'autres
outils encore bancale comme c'est un
centre de production important pour
quelques hommes et pour beaucoup
d'oreilles on y reviendra évidemment sur
les conséquences économiques pour jour
la planète mais peut-être sur sylvie
bermann ce que ce que ça signifie pour
le pouvoir chinois pour le président xi
jingping de c'est une question d'honneur
serre que il ya eu cette erreur
effectivement vous l'avez rappelé sur
sur l'absence de vaccin arn messagers
une stratégie dans laquelle ils semblent
s'obstiner qui ne fonctionne pas peut-il
faire marche arrière voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est très compliqué parce que
il a fait du la politique du coc vide du
zéro peut vite son succès personnel il
avait déclaré que ça démontrait la
supériorité du régime aux
caractéristiques chinoises sur les pays
occidentaux donc c'est pour ça que c'est
difficile et en plus il a une échéance
probablement au mois de novembre qui est
celle du 20ème congrès où il doit
normalement obtenir un troisième mandat
et se présentait avec ce succès là donc
c'est très difficile de changer de
politique aujourd'hui maintenant ce qui
concerne pékin pékin a toujours été plus
préservé que les autres villes
précisément parce que c'est le siège du
pouvoir et par exemple si vous venez
d'ailleurs en chine ou à l'étranger vous
n'arrivez pas directement à pékin vous
arriviez à tianjin à chang a justement
pour faire
la période d'isolement et de confinement
pour préserver la ville de pékin donc
c'est peut-être pour ça aussi qu'il y a
aujourd'hui moins de cas à pékin marie
holzman que que pèse l'opinion publique
dans un pays comme la chine on a vu les
images de ses concerts la de casseroles
cette semaine de façon protesté des
habitants de shanghai mais que peu pesé
l'opinion publique dans un pays comme la
chine il peut pas y avoir d'opinion
publique en chine puisqu'il ya pas de
médias enfin je veux dire y'a pas de
médias libres il ya que la propagande et
la voix du pouvoir
john john qui est une jeune ancienne
avocate qui était allé à houran pour
faire un peu des vidéos sur ce qui se
passait s'est fait arrêter et elle est
maintenant en prison un chat est
condamné à quatre ans de prison dont
vous voyez c'était pas très méchant ce
qu'elle avait fait pham binh qui avait
fait la même chose haouran il a disparu
il est en prison il a disparu donc
l'opinion publique est quand même très
au courant de ces aussi un bassin un
médecin qui avait
non il n'ya pas d'opinion publique et il
faut bien voir quand on tape sur des
casseroles et qu'on crie on ne dit rien
on ne dit pas à bâle parti communiste
chinois on crie comme un loup ou quoi
alors on peut quand même pas dans les
rues sylvo condamne la vous tenez un
placard et on dit vous avez un slogan
anti gouvernementales pour les chinois
vont pas si loin
parce que n'ose plus aller aussi loin
quoi en fait le gouvernement chinois ne
va pas si loin dans la réflexion
chinoise ne s'amuse pas à faire ce genre
de gag et est ce que l'opinion
internationale contre parce que quand on
se souvient comment pékin a vendu sa
politique sanitaire comment ils ont
rouvert et houran avec des feux
d'artifice les boîtes de nuit enfin on
se souvient de tout le poids qu'ils ont
mis pour pas qu'on appelle le govic
virus chinois et ils ont fini par
l'obtenir est-ce que les réactions
internationales l'image de la chine
internationale fait quelque chose qui
peut les faire bouger oui et non oui non
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
les chinois n'ont jamais hésité à
sacrifier la population au nom de la
politique on voit bien du temps de mao
le grand bond en avant ses 30 40
millions de morts de faim pour des
raisons politiques lorsqu'il y avait des
militants sur la place de tiananmen
il demandait simplement le dialogue avec
les dirigeants il voulait discuter un
peu et à l'époque le bloc communiste
soviétique n'était pas tombé donc ça ne
revenait pas à l'idée de vouloir
renverser le parti communiste chinois
tom chaplin n'a pas hésité à tirer sur
la population laon ce moment shanghai
provoque l'émoi mondiale enfin tout le
monde se pose des questions en disant
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce cirque
de folie c'est pas ça qui les empêche de
continuer pour le moment les dirigeants
ils ont une obsession comme vous avez
dit le 20ème congrès et il faut voir que
le secrétaire du parti communiste
chinois de shanghai céline chien il dit
ian était prévu pour monter au comité
permanent du bureau politique est là
étant donné les espèces de catastrophe
qui se déroule à shanghai il est coincé
donc je pense que sa carrière les plus
ou moins fini mais mais c'est compliqué
tout ça parce que j'y tiens voulait
faire soft à shanghai il l'avait annoncé
et dans tous les autres ont dit mais
comment la politique de 6 jean ping
c'est zéro co vide donc il faut faire et
rocco ville et il a été obligé donc là
on sera ajouté alors se montrer plus si
jean ping que si jean ping je reprends
la question de mathieu pourra entendre
votre réponse sur le comment la chine
éventuellement modules ou pas vous
disions pas sa politique en fonction de
l'opinion internationale
alors moi je pense quand même qu'elle
est très embarrassé par ces images parce
qu'elle sait très bien que c'est diffusé
dans le monde entier et que pour le coup
ce n'est pas la gloire de la chine ou à
la gloire du régime maintenant les
priorités sont des priorités politiques
et des priorités internes mais
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
ils ont déjà annoncé qu'ils allaient
assouplir un peu à shanghai et que s'ils
doivent confiné à pékin ils le feront
certainement pas de la même manière mais
c'est vrai que bon la priorité c'est en
interne mais malgré tout je pense pas
qu'il soit très heureux de voir ces
emails en fait de savoir que ces images
circulent dans le monde entier la
situation à hong kong est également
préoccupante c'est ce que disait la
directrice de campagne de reporters sans
frontières lors d'une conférence de
presse hier à londres elle elle évoque
la dégringolade de la ville dans le
classement de la liberté de la presse et
coûté cette année la plus forte chute
dans le classement a été enregistrée à
hong kong qui après l'adoption d'une loi
draconienne en matière de sécurité
intérieure et le rapprochement avec la
chine a vu se multiplier les attaques
contre les journalistes et les médias
indépendants le journaliste sont
désormais emprisonnés non seulement en
chine mais aussi en kong sur ordre de la
chine et nous avons vu en nombre
croissant de journalistes s'exiler dans
d'autres villes comme londres nous avons
assisté est la dissolution de l'apple
daily et d'autres médias indépendants ce
qui a laissé un véritable vide en terme
d'information en
baisse que le président chinois
profitent aussi de cette crise pour
mettre au pas encore un peu plus
certains opposants tellement qu'on
s'était déjà être plus
jamais trop pas quoi c'est sa fin il ya
toujours quelqu un m ont pas mais les
tous les ténors sont en prison quand on
pense que jimmy là est en prison lil jon
est en prison josh holloway est en
prison etc on peut continuer longtemps
les syndicats ont été dissous les les
associations de l'intérieur des
universités etc sont dissoutes une
statue de jens galschiot donc un
sculpteur suédois a été détruite ils ont
six étrangers ça fait aussi le tour du
monde parce que c'était un monument à la
mémoire de tiananmen
donc évidemment si jean ping ne veut
plus entendre parler de tienanmen jamais
jamais même pas hong kong
c'est sidérant ce qui s'est passé en bon
pour moi on compte que c'était un peu la
dernière barrière
contre le totalitarisme chinois pour le
monde pas seulement pour cette région là
et cette dernière barrière est tombée et
maintenant on voit que le président
chinois donnent des ordres un peu
partout par exemple là depuis quelques
mois il ya eu un millier de ouigours qui
ont été déportés de divers pays du monde
c'est à dire chez jean ping dit je veux
celui là celui là on dit ok on l'est on
les renvoie on sait qu'on les renvoie
dans des camps il ya des pays maintenant
où il ya plus de soutien pour les we go
avant ils fuyaient vers le kazakhstan
maintenant le pouvoir kasab ce temps est
aux ordres de pékin le pouvoir de n'est
pas du népal est aussi aux ordres donc
les réfugiés tibétains ne vont plus au
népal il y en a peut-être 10 par an
maintenant pas plus on ne peut plus fuir
par le népal etc etc on va parler un peu
plus d'économies maintenant avec vous
philippe guigné
comment évaluer la perte de production
de la chine en ce moment à cause de
cette épidémie de covin est ce que c'est
possible
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible c'est
trop tôt c'est trop tôt donc il ya des
impacts on sait qu'ils sont matériels
toutes les usines ne sont pas fermées ya
des films qui sont fermées et il ya des
problèmes de
logistique très important et messas
avoir un impact sur le reste du monde
parce que on voit bien que les files
d'attentes se les queues s'allongent
dans le bortsch engagé donc les bateaux
ça va changer de bateau qui aura la
charge et comme ils peuvent pas
décharger ils peuvent pas chargés ils
peuvent pas repartir donc ça des impacts
qui vont être très fort ceci dit ça
n'est pas fini donc voilà on ne rompt
par définition ne sais pas et donc on
n'a pas encore de chiffres fiables et
surtout quand on aura des chiffres ce
sera deux semaines il faudra pas oublier
que c'est ce facteur vient s'ajouter à
d'autres et que la situation économique
chinoise n'est pas très bonne depuis un
bon moment déjà ça vient s'ajouter 2 le
facteur le plus visible c'est
l'immobilier c'est là un petit peu donc
je vais parler de crise où le
dégonflement de la bulle immobilière de
manière un peu spectaculaire et très
programmée les problèmes du groupe est
fort grande depuis depuis cet hiver mais
voilà à l'immobilier en chine c'est
maintenant on a des chirons on sait que
c'est à peu près 25 ou 30% d'économies
ce secteur est en ralentissement fort et
ils vous rajoutez à ça c'était à peu
près indépendants du cpt au vide
maintenant vous rajoutez la crise du
coït s'arrange pas les choses donc mes
médias tous ses effets qui se qui se
conjuguent et ça veut dire que c'est
certaines régions qui sont à l'arrêt ou
au ralenti mais pas tout on est bien
d'accord alors pour ce qui est du coc
vide on est bien d'accord puisque locaux
vides ça va toucher plus également sa
touche shanghai ça va toucher peut-être
zhou pékin on sait pas mais
effectivement les îles qui sont confinés
sont beaucoup plus touchée que le reste
mais il ya aussi des impacts quand même
sur le reste de l'économie je vous donne
un exemple le tourisme tourisme
domestique est très très impacté les
gens ne se ne se déplace plus et ses
impacts à peu près
beaucoup de régions en chine qui sont
des régions des destinations
touristiques donc a aussi un impact
l'impact est lé plus chaud dans
certaines villes mais il est quand même
général si on parle de l'immobilier là
c'est quand même la chaîne à la face et
urbain c'est un phénomène urbain sur
l'ensemble de la chine est juste au delà
du coc id est ce que le mouvement
profond d'autoritarisme de
d'autocratie d'auxi juping peut se
conjuguer avec un développement
économique et une ouverture économique
escape à un moment où ça va casser ça
quand on veut développer un tissu
entrepreneurial ce qu'elle ait fait un
peu la chine avec des géants alibaba
vont se souvient de ce qui est arrivé à
jack mois mais est ce qu'il ya un moment
où ça va pas contrarier la croissance
économique cette montée d'autorité
redistribution effectivement il ya des
détentions ça crée des tensions et que
le parti essayer de gérer et là la
tension il ya des tensions en fait il ya
deux de sujets tant sur un premier
effectivement aujourd'hui la chine va
adopter un modèle de croissance où
l'innovation jouent un rôle très
important
à quel point un modèle fondé sur
l'innovation ils compatibles
c'est évidemment une question il faut se
garder d' apporter des réponses trop
rapide parce qu'on voit bien que dans
certains domaines l'innovation ça
progresse à pas de géant en chine mais
on voit bien que dans d'autres domaines
ça pose un problème et un deuxième sujet
de tension très très fort qui est aussi
cette volonté le contrôle consorts à
chaque instant est de plus en plus et
le rôle du secteur privé là dedans hélas
il est sûr que les choses deviennent de
plus en plus compliqué pour les polices
entrepreneurs privés alors on connaît
particulièrement bien les exemples dans
le digital mais y'a pas que cela est
donc là voilà c'est vraiment un sujet de
tension pour employés internes
et des contradictions vous savez le
parti communiste m analyser les choses
en terme de contradictions là il ya
vraiment deux contradictions assez forte
que le régime s'efforce de gérer alors
j'aimerais qu'on parle maintenant de des
liens et de l'impact peut-être delà de
la guerre en ukraine sur la diplomatie
chinoise marie holzman comment vous
allez analyser la ligne diplomatique de
la chine depuis deux mois les quoi elle
est sur une ligne de crête sur un sur un
fil
jeudi serait madame berman répondre à ça
mais j'avais envie de vous entendre
avant de donner
mon sentiment si vous voulez c'est que
je serai un peu radical tous les choix
jean ping sont mauvais
dr ping a ouvert la chine il a dit nous
devons ouvrir la chine commencer les
réformes et aller toujours de l'avant et
il avait dit toute personne qui va
contre ma décision contre 7 cette
tendance devrait être expulsé du parti
communiste chinois à ce titre je trouve
que j jean ping mériterait bien ça mais
il a fait toutes les erreurs possibles
regardez il a laissé exploser la sphère
ponctuelle de cette joueuse de tennis
avant les jo il aurait très bien pu
étouffer ça on en riant du bon pas grand
chose et tout parisien mais l'opinion
pendant il a essayé il l'a fait
disparaître mais c'était vraiment une
stupidité quoi donkey il il a pourri
l'atmosphère des jo c'était quand même
pas très malin et là il avait l'occasion
de se rabibocher avec l'occident au
moins en disant qu' ils critiquent l
attaque par l'ukraine ceci cela il a pas
fils à deux jours après l'attaqué il a
signé des accords avec la russie en
disant bon ils veulent plus votre
pétrole et de gaz mais nous oui et hop
il a signé des chèques et des chèques
pendant lé giro il a dit notre amitié
indéfectible
notre alliance est inoxydable bhl et on
va vous soutenir à fond et il le fait on
a l'impression là il a envoyé des armes
en serbie qui listent fat la chine à
envoyer des armes en serbie qu'ils
essayent de lui mais d'autres petits
feux par ci par là
pourquoi pour soutenir l'avancé de
poutine je ne comprends absolument pas
cette stratégie en termes logique pour
moi en termes logique poursuit jean picq
je comprends très bien parce que à mon
avis si poutine s'effondre si jean ping
perd son dernier grand allié à ce moment
ce moment là les américains sont pas
très chauds à
l'épée des pays voisins sont très
inquiet nous ici on commence à être
quand même assez nerveux il annonce que
le système chinois c'est le système le
meilleur il va renverser nos valeurs et
en plus il a acheté des tas de pays il a
acheté le pays en grèce il a acheté des
tas de deux magasins et d'entreprises en
italie en espagne
il continue un petit peu partout donc
l'enjeu est risquée et très risqué si
vivant est ce que vous êtes aussi
critique sur les erreurs commises par le
président chinois non parce que je pense
qu'il n'a pas le choix il n'a pas le
choix parce que les américains ont
déclaré une forme de guerre froide
contre la chine en dix ans la chine
c'est les milieux principal est le
résultat de cela et je les ai vus quand
j'étais ambassadeur en russie la
dernière année et bien il y à un
rapprochement qui s'est fait un
partenariat stratégique c'est pas une
alliance parce que les chinois ne
veulent pas d'alliance ils ont connu ça
dans dans le passé mais effectivement
moment des jeux olympiques il a dit
c'est un partenariat sans limites mais
on disait toujours qu'il fallait pas
mettre les chez les russes dans les bras
de la chine jeudi à c'est finalement ce
qui s'est passé au nom du principe
l'ennemi de mon ennemi est mon ami et
donc comme il sait très bien que de
toute façon il sera victime et enfin il
perçoit comme ça d'initiative
occidentale aux nations unies ou
ailleurs eh bien il aura besoin du
soutien de pékin du soutien de moscou je
crois que c'est ça la raison je pense
qu'en fait il est très embarrassé par
cette guerre parce que ce que lui a dit
poutine très probablement c'est ce qu'il
dit aux russes et au monde entier c'est
qu'il allait lancer une opération
militaire spécial pour aider les
populations russophones du dombass
qu'ils étaient victimes de génocide etc
etc n'a pas dû lui dire qu'il allait
faire une guerre massive donc
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la chine ne vote
pas contre la russie mais elle ne veut
pas non plus
pour le
va n'a ni pour soutenir ni dans un nid
elle est dans un mini elle s'abstient
elle dit d'ailleurs ces envois d'armes
dont parlait marie holzman abeba ont
servi par an puis aussi d'accord mais
non mais je pense que ils ont un ennemi
commun qui est aujourd'hui les états
unis et sans doute l'occident derrière
les états unis et donc je pense que si
jean ping n'a pas le choix il va pas se
rabibocher avec les américains c'est pas
possible
enfin moi je partage pas cette analyse
si on veut être un peu naïf et disant
optimiste et croire encore en l'humanité
joe biden s'est attaqué à la chine sur
des bases très concrètes il a dit vous
utilisez du travail forcé au xinjiang il
faut que ça s'arrête vous jouez pas le
jeu dans le commerce il faut que vous
respectiez les règles de l'om sait si
vous respectez pas on peut pas continuer
à jouer ensemble il a signalé toutes
sortes de choses de ce genre et c'est
vrai les chinois se sont braqués mais il
il est quand même parti sur ce chemin là
et depuis un moment chez jean ping
annonce la guerre contre l'occident il
le dit très clairement nous refusons vos
valeurs et et là il va il va vraiment à
l'encontre de l'intérêt de la chine
l'intérêt de la chine c'était de
maintenir des relations amicales avec
les américains et je pense pas qu'il
soit juste de dire ce sont les
américains qui ont attaqué les chinois
et l'otan qui a mis la russie en danger
hameau de réponse donc mais simplement
oui sur les affaires commerciales oui
sur la question des droits de l'homme
mais non quand il ya un blocus
technologie complet et c'est ce qui a
été fait par les américains est courte
qu'un bel qui est le spécialiste à la
maison blanche 10 à 10 clairement
le royaume uni a enfin comble angleterre
à l'époque a repris le flambeau de la
france nous avons repris le flambeau de
du royaume uni il est hors de question
que la chine reprennent le flambeau donc
je pense qu'il ya quand même ce qu'on a
appelé ce piège de thucydide ou une
puissance
affirmé confirmé a peur d'une puissance
montante et encore une fois c'est pas
sur la base des intérêts les intérêts
économiques commerciaux tout ça on le on
le comprend mais c'est sûr ça c'était
encore une fois quand on fait un blog
technologique ou qu'on laisse entendre
qu'il devrait y avoir un changement de
régime et qu'on se place dans une
logique idéologique et bien on comprend
que il ya une réaction de ce type et il
sait que ça ne s'arrêterait pas donc il
peut pas encore une fois aller contre
poutine même si poutine a pris les
mauvaises décisions aussi alors je
proposais alexandre tout ça poussard de
nous rejoindre tout de suite parce que
effectivement on évoque la diplomatie
chinoise c'est intéressant de savoir il
ya deux chercheurs qui sont venus au
sénat ce matin leur éclairage est
vraiment intéressant sur ce ce film
diplomatique sur lequel marche le
pouvoir chinois oui car officiellement
face à la communauté internationale la
chine tient une position de neutralité
dans cette guerre en ukraine car elle à
cet ami sans limite qu'est la russie
mais en fait cette neutralité chinoise
et bien elle va un peu plus loin pékin
apporte un soutien diplomatique et à
l'économie russe en cette période de
conflits ukrainien avec quand même un
objectif pour les chinois accroître la
dépendance de la russie vis-à-vis de la
puissance chinoise on va effectivement
écouter un chercheur de l'ifri
l'institut français des relations
internationales
auditionné ce matin au sénat
l'ukraine va nécessairement renforcer
cette dépendance vis-à-vis de la chine
dans tous les domaines dans le domaine
économique premièrement diplomatique
bien évidemment aussi mais aussi dans le
domaine technologique dans le secteur
spatial dans lequel la russie est en
train de perdre du terrain voire
peut-être à moyen terme dans le domaine
militaire et donc pékin veut donc
accroître son influence sur moscou mais
à sur la chine intérêt à ne pas trop
s'engager dans cette guerre en ukraine
tout simplement car elle en paye déjà
les conséquences
la chine n'a pas d'intérêt à s'impliquer
plus avant dans le conflit et même bien
au contraire les intérêts économiques de
pékin en ukraine ont certes été touché
françoise nicolas l'a rappelé mais ils
ne sont pas ce ne sont pas des années
des intérêts qui sont entièrement
indispensable incontournable ou vito
la chine subit les effets des sanctions
contre la russie par l'arrêt de
certaines exportations vers la russie et
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie et
des matières premières en chine prudente
dans ce conflit ukrainien d'autant que
la chine ne veut pas s'isoler trop des
occidentaux et notamment de l'union
européenne avec qui elle échange
beaucoup
la chine a besoin impérieusement de
l'union européenne qui est il est
toujours bon de le rappeler son premier
partenaire commercial
et que donc la chine a besoin d'entre
d'avoir de bonnes relations avec l'union
européenne et y compris sur des produits
d'importation aux stratégies comme les
machines-outils allemande par exemple la
chine est aussi dépendante de
l'allemagne d'une certaine manière à
pékin qui est attentif à d'éventuelles
sanctions occidentales et bien notamment
avec cet article du quotidien
britannique the financial times qui
raconte que les dirigeants chinois
seraient déjà en train d'évaluer des
sanctions occidentales contre pékin sur
le modèle des sanctions prises contre la
russie merci alexandre pour ces
informations philippe à guignes
effectivement cet article du financial
times réunion d'urgence c'était le 22
avril l'administration qui reçoit des
représentants de banques nationales et
internationales c'était quoi le but de
cette réunion c'était de d'anticiper sur
d'éventuelles sanctions liées à une
crise soit
taiwan soit une autre crise comment on
peut l'analyser sa personne n'était dans
la pièce pour écouter ce qui se dit mais
on peut imaginer que dans des
circonstances pareilles il ya beaucoup
de sujets
entre les banques les autorités d'avoir
sur la question des des banques
chinoises c'est quand même frappant que
de tout ce qu'on peut voir
elle respecte des sanctions contre la
russie et ne cherche pas à les contrer à
les contourner et la raison est simple
elles ont les les autorités chinoises et
les banques sont tout à fait conscientes
du pouvoir américain dans ce domaine de
l'ain et du des dégâts que pourraient
faire des sanctions américaines serait
prendre le risque d'être à
prendre ils ont quelques exemples
ce qui est arrivé à des banques
occidentales ou simplement l'exemple qui
est arrivé à hawaï de ce qui est arrivé
à roanne voilà donc ils sont tout à fait
conscients de tout à fait conscient de
cela maintenant je crois que le ras le
bol des questions est-ce qu'ils ont
parlé de sanctions je crois qu'il faut
pas mettre ça dans le contexte logeant
ce taiwan ce terrain on pourrait donner
l'impression que
l'invasion de taiwan est imminente et là
je crois que c'est tout à fait pas tout
à fait le cas mais en revanche ce qui
est sûr c'est que là aussi il ya un
phénomène de long terme qui est alors ça
fait très longtemps mais il est enrichi
points sont conscientes et inquiètes de
leur dépendance vis-à-vis du reste du
monde du point de vue économique et il
interprète de cinq ans une vulnérabilité
on peut citer plein d'exemples
l'approvisionnement d'énergie la chine
est le plus gros importateur mondial de
pétrole et de et de gaz le deuxième de
gaz naturel donc c'est déjà une
vulnérabilité très importante à un autre
domaine céder les puces électroniques
c'est le principal poste de
déficit fin de
concession d'accord chinois c'est plus
que le pétrole est là on a bien vu à
quel point ce qu'une arme dans les mains
des autorités américaines parce que
c'est ça qui a tué la moitié du business
derouet donc la partie téléphone mobile
de droit donc il ya cette inquiétude qui
est très forte depuis depuis longtemps
maintenant et qui a et qui s'est encore
ravivées depuis si tim kaine et ça se
traduit par plein de choses une
politique industrielle donc un plan
industriel made in china 2025 ou très
clairement les objectifs c'est de
réduire la dépendance de l'économie
chinoise vis-à-vis de la technologie
étrangère dans plein de secteurs tous
les secteurs importants le tout ce qui a
trait à la décarbonation etc ce terrain
ces voix là il s'agit de que la chine ne
sera plus d'un moment dépendante des
importations donc on a chaud plan
industriel on l'a dans plein de domaines
vous avez une des grandes politiques
économiques de sit-in ping depuis
maintenant au moins trois ans ça
s'appelle or c'est un peu décès c'est
toujours en termes codés c'est la double
circulation alors qu'elle faisait dans
la double de circulation se fait dire
que l'économie repose sur deux choses ce
qui s'appellera circulatory et survient
sur l'international donc dès le commerce
extérieur c'est la circulation
domestique plutôt la demande domestique
et donc la volonté le but de cette
politique de double circulation se fait
de rééquilibrer et de diminuer
l'importance de la circulation extérieur
par rapport
au vide forcément ça paraît compliqué
donc ça on peut parler de parenthèse
sylvie bermann non je voulais ajouter
l'autre chose c'est que il y a un
travail qui est fait sur le hub and
digital parce que aussi bien quelqu'un
comme au secours recherchent une des
dollarisation de l'économie qu'ils
essaient de d'une part maintenant
d'avoir de plus en plus de contrats en
yuan et à l'avenir effectivement de
pouvoir avoir ce lundi j'étais quand
même surfer pas demain mais ont tous
bien sûr et réfléchir sur le registre
est journée sanctions sur taïwan quand
même la chine revendique toujours taïwan
comme une partie de son de son
territoire est-ce que ce qui se passe en
ukraine peut quand même freiné
influencer le lait les audaces où les
velléités chinoises en la matière on
sait pas quels sont les velléités
chinoises il sauf que on sait qu'il
considère que taiwan fait partie
intégrante de la chine ne veut pas dire
qu'ils vont l'occuper dans les médias
mais en tout cas il me paraît évident
que les chinois qui étudient
sérieusement toutes situations vont
étudier les conséquences de la guerre
d'agression en ukraine des conséquences
économiques du système de sanction mis
par les occidentaux de la fourniture des
armes enfin bien évidemment qu'ils vont
étudier cela et si je puis la résistance
des ukrainiens qui est qui est une
surprise et
qui est probablement une surprise pour
pour les dirigeants chinois taïwanais se
meut se prépare à une invasion ou à une
attaque chinoise c'est où c'est quelque
chose c'est comme ça un peu
tout à fait au courant loin de vie avec
la menace de au moins mille missiles
pointés en direction de l'île partir des
côtes du fujian mais j'ai envie de dire
c'est par essence a fait ça fait 30 ans
40 ans que les chinois accumule les
missiles en direction de taïwan donc je
crois que maintenant il y espère qu'un
jour la chine va changer et que le
modèle de la démocratie taïwanaise pour
un faire tache d'huile alors bon ça
c'est un vraiment un vieux un voeu pieux
on n'en voit pas que ça va se produire
très vite mais on ne sait pas ça peut
quand même se produire en revanche les
américains se sont engagés très
fermement que si la chine attaqué il
serait là pour défendre taïwan les
japonais aussi les australiens aussi
donc bon lait des taiwanais ont quand
même un sens de la philosophie
exceptionnel
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat